Wir blicken jetzt auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Was ist los in England, Spanien, Italien und Frankreich? Das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Alexi Menü, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel und Alex Treuker jetzt hier in der Rasenfunk Ligatur. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich grüße meine Runde. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Wir werden keinerlei Zeit verschwenden, sondern wir steigen direkt rein in die Ligen. Christian, du darfst sehr gerne mal anfangen. Was gibt's denn aus der Serie A so zu berichten?
Ja, sehr gerne. Erst mal Hallo in die illustre Runde. Ich würde heute gerne, nachdem wir es ja die letzten Wochen immer wieder mal kurz angerissen haben, aber meistens bei den MVPs sollte man jetzt vielleicht nochmal kurz darüber reden, was Atalanta gerade wieder diese Saison so macht. Also die Faktenlage ist, glaube ich, relativ eindeutig. Ein Punkt, also wahnsinnig spannender Kampf in der Serie A an der Tabellenspitze. Ein Punkt hinter Napoli. Atalanta ist total dran. Und ich würde heute gerne mal im Fokus– wir haben ja öfter schon über Atalanta, über das Gasparini-System geredet– und da war ja meistens so ein Mittelpunkt, da stand dann, ja, die sind ja unfassbar intensiv und dieses 1 gegen 1-Pressing übers ganze Feld. Also wahnsinnig unangenehm, der Radiolaspuch wie ein Besuch beim Zahnarzt. Aber vielleicht sollte man jetzt auch mal den Fokus drauf richten, dass das eine unfassbar gute offensive Mannschaft ist. Was die diese Saison jetzt einfach verlässlich bringen, offensiv auch. Also es ist viel mehr als dieses intensive Unangenehme. Sondern fangen wir mal mit ein paar Zahlen an. Atalanta hat den besten Angriff der Serie A. Atalanta gibt die meisten Torschüsse der Serie A an. Atalanta hat mit Abstand die meisten Ballaktionen im gegnerischen Strafraum. Die meisten Großchancen rausgespielt. Also ich würde gerne mal den Fokus drauf legen, dass es eben mehr ist, als dieses intensive Unangenehm. Sondern eben auch, was Gasperini da wirklich mit Ball mittlerweile etabliert hat. Und da passt ja auch ganz gut, dass heute, wir zeigen am Donnerstag auf, am Dienstagabend in der Champions League in Bern. Ja, das ist Bern, ist mir schon klar. Aber auf dem Kunststraßen musst du dann doch erst mal sechs Stück machen. Und die machen sie halt auch, in dem Lukman 90 Minuten auf der Bank sitzt und Ederson gesperrt fehlt zum Beispiel. Also das nur so als kleine, als kleiner Einstieg.
Ja, also bemerkenswerte Serie, die da Atalanta gemacht hat und eben mit viel, viel Offensive. Aber wenn unser MVP der letzten Sendung, Lukman, auf der Bank sitzt, dann ist vielleicht Punkt Nummer zwei, Breite des Kaders.
Genau, definitiv. Also das ist auch ein Punkt, deswegen habe ich es auch explizit angesprochen. Also Lukman und Ederson sind für mich, dazu kommen wir vielleicht auch noch. Also ich finde, in den letzten Jahren war oft die Rede auch Atalanta eher gut, das funktioniert halt so gut, weil das Gasparini-System so perfekt eingespielt ist. Und das klang ja auch immer wieder mal durch. Das sind halt Spieler, die halt im Gasparini-System so gut funktionieren. Aber gerade wenn ich mir zum Beispiel Lukman und Ederson hernehme, das sind für mich internationale Topspieler mittlerweile. Also gerade Ederson, was Ederson in dieser Saison wieder spielt, für mich der beste Mittelfeldspieler der Serie A, weil ja Giannullo bisher Verletzungsprobleme auch hatte, das ist für mich einer der Top-Mittelfeldspieler in ganz Europa. Also mittlerweile finde ich, ist er auch die individuelle Klasse. Nicht nur, dass du sagst, es sind diese Gasparini-Spieler, diese Atalanta-Spieler, sondern sie haben sich auch dahingehend entwickelt. Das eben, und da finde ich Ederson und Lukman, ein perfektes Beispiel. Hien, einer der besten Verteidiger der Serie A. Decquetelara jetzt in seiner zweiten Saison, der brutale Zahlen hat. Ich habe bei diesem... Decquetelara hat jetzt in Bern zwei Tore, drei Vorlagen. Das gab es noch nie von einem Belgier, glaube ich. Gab es auch noch nie von einem Serie A-Spieler in der Champions League. Und da kam eine Opta-Statistik. Decquetelara hat im Kalenderjahr 2024 nur Kevin de Bruyne hat eine einzige Vorlage mehr geliefert als Decquetelara, sozusagen wettbewerbsübergreifend. Und da kannst du jetzt die Reihe fortsetzen. Retegi haben wir ja auch schon gehabt. Retegi steht jetzt, glaube ich, bei 14 oder 15 Saison-Toren. Also ja, es ist schon, sie funktionieren wunderbar im Atalanta-System, aber es ist halt mittlerweile auch eben, wie du sagst, eine Breite, eine Tiefe im Kader, von der sich andere, auch italienische Top-Vereine, also die würden sich danach strecken, dass die gerade im offensiven Bereich so viele Alternativen haben. Also das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Und da dürfen wir nicht vergessen, Skamaka, der Neuner, mit einer der wichtigsten der vergangenen Saison, der sich ja im Sommer, im August, das Kreuzband gerissen hat. Bei Atalanta sind sie hoffnungsfroh, dass er Ende Januar vielleicht auch wieder mit dabei ist. Also da kommt ja nochmal, muss man jetzt logisch abwarten, wie gut er zurückkommt, wie lange das braucht, dass er wieder in Spielrhythmus kommt. Aber da kommt potenziell noch mal krasse Qualität dazu. Und das ist einfach beeindruckend, was Atalanta auf allen Ebenen da macht.
Und das ja auch in der Champions League. Also auch da noch umgeschlagen. Also was heißt auch da in der Serie A? Gab es am Anfang der Saison ja Niederlagen, aber jetzt schon sehr lange keine mehr. Aber international wie national. Glaubst du denn, dass Atalanta auch die Kraft hätte und– keine Ahnung– Mindset oder was auch immer du sagen willst, da jetzt durchzuziehen, zum Beispiel in der Liga, wirklich an Napoli dran zu bleiben?
Also ich muss, was ich eingehend auch noch, was für mich die Grundlage dieser Entwicklung, dieses nächsten Steps für mich bei Atalanta in dieser Saison ist, ist dieser Europa League-Sieg gegen Leverkusen. Weil die letzten Jahre hat der Atalanta immer schon viel Lob bekommen für ihre Art zu spielen, für ihre Entwicklung, die sie auch als Club genommen haben. Und es klang halt immer so ein bisschen mit, ach schau, die machen das großartig. Aber es hat halt am Ende dieser Silberware gefehlt. Dieser, sag ich mal, auch dieser Pokal in den Händen, der halt allen klarmacht, hey, mit dem Weg, den wir hier gehen, können wir halt auch Triumph erholen. Und dieses 3-0 gegen Leverkusen, das hat, glaube ich, wirklich bei vielen Spielern diesen letzten mentalen Step gebracht, dass die jetzt wissen, okay, hey, das was sie hier machen. Also die waren davor schon überzeugt von dem Weg, den sie gehen. Aber jetzt haben sie halt gesehen, und diese Europa League Saison letztes Jahr war eine besondere, weil ungeschlagenes Leverkusen dominieren im Finale, 3-0 an der Enfield Road gewinnen. Also das war zwar nur Europa League, aber das hatte schon auch immer wieder Spuren von Champions League. Und deswegen, glaube ich, war das so dieser letzten Schritt, den sie gemacht haben, diese mentalen Step zu wissen, okay, mit unserem Weg können wir auch ganz Großes erreichen. Und ja, um jetzt auf deine Frage zu kommen, ich traue ihnen definitiv zu, dass sie im Skoletta-Rennen bleiben, denn das war ja eines der Probleme der letzten Jahre. Sie hatten immer und gerade im Herbst meistens so eine Phase, wo sie einen zu großen Abstand aufreißen haben lassen, und den haben sie dann irgendwann nicht mehr gefüllt. Und jetzt sind sie aber mittendrin. Sie sind dabei, haben einen Punktrekord nach 13 Spieltagen. Noch nie hat Atalanta so viele Punkte in der Serie A, in ihrer Clubhistorie. Sie sind dran. Und auch in der Champions League ganz ehrlich, ich wünsche jetzt schon jedem, der Atalanta in der K.o.-Runde bekommt viel Spaß, weil die– und das ist wirklich deren Selbstverständnis– ganz egal, ob die bei Real spielen, ob die gegen City spielen, ob die gegen Liverpool spielen, die werden ihren Spielstil nicht ändern. Und deswegen glaube ich, sind die vom Gefühl her in K.o.-Duellen, im Hin- und Rückspiel, noch mal gefährlicher. Wenn die ihre Top-Spiele haben, von denen sie immer wieder welche haben, und dann einfach mal im Hinspiel zwei, drei Buden machen, dann wird es auch für Große im Rückspiel schwierig. Also ich sehe im Moment, ich sehe die echt auf allen Ebenen, zumindest mal mit sehr guten Aussichten. Was da halt auch mit reinspielt, die Intensität ist ja weiterhin die gleiche. Also was die läuferisch bringen, athletisch, deswegen sehe ich bei denen auch kein Problem, muss ich sagen im Vergleich zu vielen anderen großen, die haben wenig Probleme aufgrund der Doppelbelastung. Und die Breite im Kader haben wir ja angesprochen, weil so einer wie Samadžić, um noch einen Namen zu droppen, den sie jetzt im Sommer geholt haben, dem baut Gasperini halt langsam ein. Der steht auch schon bei drei Saison-Touren. Wer das Tor in Bern gesehen hat, vielleicht nochmal anschauen, das war eine sehr feine Pude. Also da ist Kreativität da, da kommen immer neue Elemente dazu. Quadrado, Quadrado glaube ich, hatten die wenigsten auf dem Zettel, den baut er jetzt auch. Der hat jetzt erst einmal 90 Minuten in Bern gespielt. Also es sind so viele Varianten, die sie haben und so viele Optionen. Und ja, ich traue ihnen in der Serie A alles zu und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich traue ihnen auch in der Champions League. Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viel zu.
Es kommen jetzt drei ganz interessante Spiele für Atalanta. Die Roma auswärts, Milan zu Hause und dann zu Hause gegen ihre Air Madrid. Und wenn wir gerade gesagt haben, wie gut Atalanta in der Champions League da steht, genau das Gegenteil ist real. Die sind gerade auf Platz 24, ist alles noch eng beieinander. Am Platz muss man sich nicht aufhängen. Aber sollte Atalanta auch gegen Real durchziehen, dann sehe ich schon nie, dass sie hier ein Thema mitbringen.
Und Barca kommt auch noch in der Champions League. Also da kann man sich auch noch drauf freuen, die kriegen Real und Barca noch in der Champions League. Und wie gesagt, also es ist wirklich, ich kann es nur jedem raten, schaut euch mal ein Atalanta-Spiel an, weil wie gesagt, es ist mehr als nur dieses unangenehme 1 gegen 1, sondern es ist wirklich auch, wenn man sich die letzten Wochen die Spiele, also das auch nur einzuordnen, seit im Oktober und November, glaube ich, haben sie von 10 Spielen 9 gewonnen. Das eine, das sie nicht gewonnen haben, war 0-0 gegen Celtic zu Hause. Und da hatten sie Expected Goals von 2,4 und 22 Torabschlüsse. Also da lag es nicht daran, dass sie schlecht waren, da lag es daran, dass sie die Buden halt nicht gemacht haben. Aber du kriegst eigentlich verlässlich, kriegst du offensive Produktion, offensive Quantität auch. Und einfach mal darauf achten, wie viele Atalanta-Spieler in wahnsinnig vielen Phasen des Spiels aus dem Spiel heraus im gegnerischen Strafraum sind. Also du hast fast immer vier, fünf Atalanta-Spieler, die den Strafraum besetzen. Hat man ja auch schon oft die aus der Dreierkette, die da vorne mit reingehen. Also das ist offensiv, das kann sehr erdrückend sein. Und im Moment haben sie halt, wie gesagt, diese mentale Verfassung, dass sie wissen, was sie können dazu, das Athletische, das ja immer die Basis von Gasparini ist. Und im Moment sind die unfassbar eklig zu bespielen. Eine letzte Zahl noch dazu, weil wir jetzt haben viel Lukman, Retegi, die grossen Namen. So ein Mario Pasalic. Ich glaube, der haut jetzt keinem vom Hocker, wenn man den Namen mal droppt quasi. Da wird jetzt nicht ganz Fußball Europa so, oh mein Gott, das ist ein riesen Nummer. Also Mario Pasalic steht mittlerweile in der Serie A bei 50 Toren als Mittelfeldspieler. Also der hat über die Jahre bei Atalanta einfach jedes Jahr macht er seine 5, 6, 7 Buden. Einmal, glaube ich, hat er 9 oder 10 gemacht. Und ja, der spielt manchmal auf der 10, aber die 10 bei der Atalanta ist auch keine klassische 10. Der spielt auch oft auf der Doppel-6. Und der ist einfach über die Jahre als jetzt nicht einer der großen Namen auf 50 Serie A Tore gekommen als Mittelfeldspieler. Und das, finde ich, ist auch so einfach nur ein kleines Bild, das zeigt, dass diese Atalantasystematik wirklich, ja, ich würde sagen, jetzt noch mal in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren noch mal auf ein neues Niveau gehoben wurde. Und abschließender Satz von mir, ich bin, wenn in 20, 30, 40 Jahren über diese, gerade wenn über den Trainer, glaube ich, gesprochen wird, dann ist ja klar, dann werden die Guardiolas und die Angelottis und die Klops werden da logisch völlig zu Recht als Erste genannt werden. Aber ich glaube schon, dass bei vielen, die da noch zurückschauen, die vielleicht auch so ein bisschen den großen Blick auf den europäischen Fußball haben, ich glaube, dass Gasperini in der Rückblende auch einen besonderen Platz kriegen wird. Weil er halt einfach das wirklich über viele Jahre jetzt einfach wieder sich teilweise immer wieder neu erfindet. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, zu Beginn dieser Saison, Skamaka verletzt sich am Kreuzband, dann ist es das Theater mit Coop Miners, der drei Wochen lang nicht trainiert, dann auch zu Juwe geht, den sie verkaufen, aber dafür für knapp 60 Millionen Euro. Und am Ende kurz vor Transferschluss, das weiß Alexis aus, war auch noch das Luckmann-Theater, weil PSG plötzlich angeklopft hat und sehr viel Geld auf den Tisch gelegt hat. Das lassen die aber alles an sich abprallen, erfinden sich wieder mal neu und stehen jetzt halt wieder richtig gut da. Ich weiß, ich habe es schon oft gesagt, aber ich finde es wirklich beeindruckend, was Atalanta da als Club, Gasperini, die Spieler der Club auch, wie sojös sie wirtschaftlich arbeiten, da jetzt schon über viele Jahre tun.
Aber wirklich. Und jeder, der die Ligatur hört, der weiß das schon seit mindestens zwei Jahren. Ich glaube, da habe ich irgendwann in der Zeit der Wortspiele noch, gab es den Titel, sag niemals, Gasperini oder irgendwie sowas, als wir eben über die ganzen Schüler Gasperinis gesprochen haben, die über Europa sich verteilen.
Genau. Also er hat wirklich auch seine Ideen. Auch gerade dieses, ich würde sagen, vor Gasperini war die Dreierkette oder Fünferkette verpönt als ja total defensiv hinten reinstellen. Gasperini hat das auch gezeigt, dass du auch mit einer Dreierkette wahnsinnig mutig, wahnsinnig aktiv, wahnsinnig offensiven Fußball spielen kannst. Und schau dir mal hinteran, auch bei Insagi, da sind Gasperini-Elemente drin, wenn du dir anschaust, was Bavar und Bastoni da machen aus der Dreierkette heraus. Also Gasperini ist wirklich stilprägend, definitiv.
Diese Info sollte man manchen Bundesligisten zutragen. Man kann auch mit einer Dreierkette offensiv spielen. Aber das ist jetzt mein Problem und nicht euer Problem. Lasst mal in die Premier League rüber wandern. Uli, was würdest du denn sagen? Worüber sollen wir als erstes reden?
Ja, das ist jetzt die große Frage. Wahrscheinlich einfach nur, weil es schöner ist über Leicester City. Die haben ja einen Trainer gewechselt. Tatsächlich überraschend für mich kam das am Montag dann, dass die reagieren würden und haben jetzt, ich glaube, zumindest zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme ist das so auch schon ihren neuen Trainer gefunden, den Rudolf van Nisselrooy. Das heißt…
Aber er geht nicht zum HSV.
Nee, also das ist typisch deutsch, ne? Rudolf van Nisselrooy hat über seine Zeit beim HSV gesagt, das war der größte Fehler meines Lebens. Und dann denkt man, jetzt geht er zum HSV. Da ist schon klar, dass er sich nicht zwei Sekunden damit beschäftigen würde. Aber…
Okay.
Na ja.
Okay, also er geht zu Lester. Und wird er in… werden wir in ein paar Monaten sagen, lässt er es lieber wieder bleiben oder kann das gut funktionieren?
Ich kann darauf nicht kontern, weil mir jetzt auf die Schnelle am Vormittag nichts einfällt. Ich glaube, das hätte er besser bleiben lassen sollen, Tatsache. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl… Also ich dachte, der stand gut da nach seiner kurzen Zeit jetzt bei United. Das hat außerordentlich gut geklappt. Und vorher hat er nach seiner Zeit bei PSV schon ein paar Zweifel gelassen, ob das alles so gut ist. Ich habe auch aus Manchester zunächst mal unterschiedliches gehört, wie sie ihn finden, haben ihn jetzt aber dann, so wie sich das auch gehört, von einem Club mit großer Klasse, haben ihn dann ja schon mit netten Worten verabschiedet und auch wissen lassen, dass der wirklich gute Arbeit gemacht hat und dass der sehr, sehr, sehr beliebt war und sowieso ja ist im Publikum. Aber ich dachte, der wartet etwas länger, bis er zurückkommt auf die Bühne, weil er ja schon in so ziemlich jedes sich bietende Mikrofon gesagt hat, dass er eines Tages gerne Manchester United-Trainer wäre. Und dann dachte ich vom Gefühl her, der kann vielleicht nach diesem kurzen Stint jetzt etwas Besseres bekommen als Leicester, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen möchte, dass das nicht eine gute Opportunität ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich für jeden Trainer in der Premier League immer so, dass einer dieser Plätze den zu bekommen, das ist nichts Schlechtes. Aber Leicester hat schon ein paar Probleme, die jetzt über die normale Sachlage auf den Platz hinausgehen. Also da gibt es wieder strukturelle Dinge, die nicht gut passen. Und deswegen hat es mich auch verwundert, dass sie reagieren oder reagiert haben jetzt mit Steve Cooper, weil ja, die letzten beiden Spiele gegen Manchester United passenderweise, das war für Nesclore als letztes Spiel. Und gegen Chelsea vor allen Dingen, die erste Hefte, die waren nicht nur nicht gut, sondern die wurden sogar kontinuierlich ziemlich so schwach, dass es mich fast zum Teil verwundert hat, wie sich ein Team so ergeben kann. Auf der anderen Seite haben viele, viele Statistiken, die jetzt nicht unbedingt nur Gegentore oder kassierte Schüsse betragen, eigentlich Gutes gesagt und das ist immer die etwas billige Frage. Aber was haben die denn jetzt erwartet? Und ich glaube, da liegt so ein bisschen der Hase im Pfeffer. Das sagen sie auch tatsächlich. Sie denken nicht, dass sie gegen den Abstieg spielen, sondern sie denken, dass sie eigentlich Richtung Platz 12 schielen könnten, müssten, sollten. Und das halte ich für maßlos überzogen.
Weil ja auch entsprechend die Ergebnisse aktuell nicht so wirklich passen. Ich meine, der Tabellenkonstellation nachher kann ich das schon nachvollziehen, dass man eben sagt, den berühmten Impuls zu setzen. Denn Leicester hat eben so ein bisschen abreißen lassen. Also im Grunde so, ab United, ab Platz 12, da beginnen so die Teams mit 16 Punkten. Vielleicht kann man noch Born with West Ham dazunehmen, 15 Punkte. Aber Leicester mit 10 auf Rang 16 wirklich schon ein bisschen abgeschlagen. Aber weil du das schon so mal kurz angedeutet hast, dass da quasi mehr im Argen liegt als jetzt nur Ergebnisse oder nur der Trainer. Was ist es denn, was da im Argen liegt?
Geht zurück eigentlich in die Corona-Zeit, als das alles so richtig zum Vorschein kam. Oder vielleicht, man muss wahrscheinlich von ganz vorne aufziehen. Also 2016 Meister geworden. Haben wir glaube ich alle noch irgendwie einigermaßen vor Augen und werden wir wahrscheinlich auch vermutlich alle nie vergessen. Und danach ist es oder dieser Titel kam so zustande, dass Leicester eigentlich immer sehr, sehr clever verpflichtet hat, Werte geschaffen hat und dann immer so im Halbjahreszyklus jemanden geholt hat und hat gehen lassen. Geholt hat, jemanden hat gehen lassen. Das heißt, sie haben immer schon den Ersatz jeweils im Kader gehabt gegen ganz schön viel Geld. Das Ganze damals aber noch unter dem alten Besitzer VK, der ja dann, auch das haben wir tragischerweise noch vor Augen, mit dem Helikopterabsturz ums Leben gekommen ist. Und irgendwann so in der Covid-Zeit haben sie sich gedacht, nachdem sie ein paar Mal auch im Europapokal gewesen sind und sich als etablierten Premier League-Gisten betrachtet haben, dass sie jetzt nicht mehr zwingend verkaufen müssen, sondern jetzt können sie behalten. Und haben dann teilweise Spieler so lange gehalten, dass die fast nicht mehr erkennbar waren, weil sie einfach nicht mehr gut genug waren in Krisensituationen und dann ablösefrei gegangen sind. Jurid Hielemanns ist wahrscheinlich so ein Riesenbeispiel, der bei Leicester in der Pokalsiegersaison auch nicht so lange her richtig, richtig gut aussah. Dann haben sie entschieden, den behalten wir, obwohl es da 40, 50 Millionen Angebote gab. Und am Ende lassen sie ihn ablösefrei ziehen. Und dann kommt Corona und das ist dann nochmal leider Gottes ein strukturelles Problem. Vick als Sohn Eierwaard hat übernommen und die Familie, deren Nachnamen ich nicht aussprechen möchte, da kannst du jetzt den Wortspiel überlegen, bis ich fertig bin mit diesem Monolog hier. Der hat dann übernommen. Man sagt, das ist ein ganz netter Kerl, aber da muss man sich nicht so viele Meinungen anhören und die Hände sind gar nicht so vorgehalten. So ziemlich jeder sagt, der hat absolut keinen Plan, was er da tut. Und das Problem ist, die haben ihr Geld, diese Familie im Tourismus gemacht und das ist während Corona völlig zusammengebrochen, sodass der Verein Leicester auch keine Spritze mehr bekommen können. Das gepaart mit, du hast keine Werte mehr drin und jetzt kommt dann sogar noch PSA mit rein, also diese Nachhaltigkeitsregelungen. Sie haben in der Zwischenzeit trotzdem noch investiert, wenn auch nicht mehr so viel und schon gar nicht clever, haben seit Jahren nichts auf den sämtlichen Strukturen geändert. Die Geschäftsführerin ist seit 2011 die gleiche, der Sportdirektor seit 2014 der gleiche. Denen man auch nachsagt, dass sie sich überhaupt nicht in den modernen Fußball mit eingearbeitet haben. Das heißt, sie haben im Recruitment so gut wie nichts gemacht und haben trotzdem wahrscheinlich immer noch einen Punktabzug vor der Brust, der in der Rückrunde reinklicken wird. Weshalb wahrscheinlich, das ist zumindest meine Conclusio, jetzt der Panik-Button gedrückt wurde, weil sie wissen, dass sie brauchen eine Serie in der Hinrunde, weil sie sich eigentlich sicher sein können, dass PSA ein zweites Mal ins Eck kommt. Beim ersten Mal haben sie erfolgreich geklagt, gab keinen Punktabzug. Da haben sie, so sagt man, ich weiß es nicht, aber so sagt man, ein Schlupfloch gefunden. Beim zweiten Mal wird es nicht so glümplich ausgeben. Das weiß der Verein auch, wenn ich mir das so richtig anhöre, wie sie alles sprechen. Und dann gibt es noch das Thema, was natürlich auch nicht besonders geschickt ist. Du hast in Steve Cooper den Trainer eines Lokalrivalen, Nottingham Forest, der da eine absolute Legende ist, geholt. Das war von vornherein so, dass man gesagt hat, boah, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe es eher als positiv betrachtet, weil der zumindest dieses ganze PSA-Chaos schon kennt und da ganz ruhig wirken konnte. Aber das ist bei den Fans nicht so richtig angekommen. Und dann gab es ja noch die Bilder. Spieler sind nach dem Chelsea-Spiel nach Kopenhagen geflogen und im Nachklub halten die einen Schild hoch mit Enzo Marezka, der sie gerade geschlagen hat. Das hilft nicht.
Ohje, Lestra. Also, Vickai Srivada da Parapa heißt er. Wortspiel fällt mir keins zu einer, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es im Scatman-Song einmal Scatman vorkommt. Ja, ja, ja. Wir gehen von einem Verein, bei dem es drunter und drüber geht, zu einem anderen Verein, bei dem es drunter und drüber geht, der spielt in der Ligue 1. Und Alexi, wenn du ein Thema schon ankündigst, mit Chaos in– in diesem Fall– Rennen, also dann lehne ich mich zurück, entspanne mich und höre dir sehr gerne zu.
Also ich werde versuchen, nicht so lange wieder Christian zu sein, weil sonst ist es bald dunkel. Und– Schatzfeiert! Alles gut gewesen. Nee, ich habe Rennen ausgewählt, weil es war schon ein Verein in den letzten Jahren, der immer besser wurde, auch von den finanziellen Mitteln her. Und man hatte das Gefühl, es kann eine Mannschaft sein, die richtig stabil spielt, sich entwickelt und vielleicht mal regelmäßig an der Champions League teilnimmt. Man hat als Eigentümer einer der reichsten Franzosen mit François Pinot nur– ja, Rennes ist zwar sein Spielzeug, aber er gibt auch nicht so viel Geld aus, ist relativ geizig. Und deswegen gab es zuletzt auch in der Strategie des Vereins immer wieder Fehler auf der Trainerposition, aber auch in der Gestaltung des Kaders. Also wenn man sich den Transfermarkt im Fernsehen in den Sommer ansieht, dann sieht man viele Fehler, viele Flops und kaum Spieler, die zugeschlagen haben. Man hat natürlich in den letzten Jahren viele Juwelen verkauft, insbesondere in der Bundesliga. Jetzt muss man den Belé, aber noch näher natürlich Mathis Tell, zum FC Bayern oder Bel Ocean im Sommer zu Bayern und Philippe Wacousen. Und jetzt steht man, glaube ich, mit einem Punkt von der Abschätzung entfernt. Jetzt hat man den Trainer gewechselt, Julien Stéphan ist entlassen worden, endlich mal. Und für ihn Jorge Sampaoli zu holen in die Britannie, ja, kann das wirklich klappen? Wenn man so hört, auch in Rennes, er soll bald auch wieder Platz machen für Frank S., so der aufkommende Trainer, der übrigens auch unter Vertrag steht, nämlich bei Niza seit Saisonanfang. Also viel Chaos, viel oder zu wenig Struktur. Der neue Sportdirektor mit Massa, den Christian bestimmt kennt, der bisher keinen guten Eindruck hinterlässt, weil man weiß nicht wirklich, was er vorhat. Man dachte, er wird nicht lange auf Stéphane setzen, dann entlässt er ihn und holt aus der Not ein bisschen der Panik Jorge Sampaoli raus. Man hätte schon gedacht, dass er eine andere Idee hätte. Und deswegen weiß man nicht wirklich, wo es mit dem Rennen weitergeht. Diese Saison auch nicht international dabei. Schon letzte Saison hat man eine sehr enttäuschende Saison gezeigt. Und deswegen macht man sich schon Sorgen, dass der Verein Nummer 1 in der Britannien bald vielleicht die Seelen streichen muss und vielleicht sogar absteigt. Weil man sieht keine Verbesserung. Rein spielerisch war das auch ein Armutszeugnis. Letzten Sonntag in Lille bei der Premier League von Sampaoli. Und deswegen greift momentan das größte Chaos der Liga.
Aber wie kann das sein, dass jemand gerade erst anfängt und du dann aber schon sagst, naja, also kann sein, dass der auch bald wieder gehen muss und du präsentierst uns auch schon quasi seinen Nachfolger. Musst du da viel spekulieren oder gibt es da schon konkrete Berichte zu oder wie ist das einzuschätzen?
Das sind halt so Infos von den Insidern, die tagtäglich folgen, natürlich nicht vom Verein, aber die wollen halt einen französischen Trainer, der viele Jahre bleiben könnte, also auf Kontinuität setzen. Und die haben gesehen, dass Franck Elsinons heraushagende Arbeit geleistet hat. Er ist gerade in Niza gelandet vor einem halben Jahr und dort macht er auch keine schlechte Arbeit. Niza ist auch an der Champions League, nah am Podium in der Ligue 1, ist auch noch in der Europa League dabei, auch wenn man bisher nicht gut abgeschnitten hat. Aber warum hat man sich Gedanken mit so einem Trainer, wo man jetzt St. Pauli holt, wie man jetzt nur einen Effekt mit dem neuen Trainer, der Ex-Trainer von Olympique Marseille, und man weiß, mittel- und langfristig wird es eh nicht klappen, also St. Pauli bis Sommer und dann auf ein komplett neues Gesicht setzen. Das sind so Gedanken. Das zeigt einfach das Spiegelbild, dass es bei Rennes momentan keiner wirklich durchblickt, was bei den Fans natürlich für viele Sorgen sorgt.
Und was würde der Ligue 1 verloren gehen, wenn man den letzten Verein aus der Britannier verliert, außer eben, dass es quasi regional dort dann keinen Erstligisten mehr gibt, kurze Zeit?
Eigentlich wird keiner Rennes relativ vermissen, außer Rennes selber. Ich meine auch die Nachbarn. Ich darf ehrlich sein, oder, Max?
Ja, ja. Ich mache dir die Tür auf, dass du mir jetzt von der tollen Fußballkultur, von Rennes erzählst und von den treuen Fans und so weiter. Aber du kannst auch– klar, du darfst ehrlich sein, logisch.
Ich überlege auf Vergleich bei Deutschland. Das ist mir gerade schwer. Zum Beispiel die Nachbarn in der Britannien, ob Rest, ob Yangon, die rassen alle Rennes. Die werden sicherlich Champagner aufmachen und viel Kratz essen, wenn die tatsächlich im Mai absteigen sollten. Aber ansonsten findest du in Paris, in Marseille, in Lyon, in Lille, in Nizza, in Straßburg keinen Rennes-Fan. Das gibt es einfach nicht. Es ist schon ein sehr traditionsreicher Verein im Westen Frankreichs, aber das war es schon. Deswegen würde man zum Beispiel mehr Lyon, Lille oder Nizza vermissen als Tadren, der nur ein Regionalferein ist. Daran ist auch der Eigentümer schuld, weil er einfach zu wenig aus dem Mittel gemacht hat und sich nicht zu 100 Prozent investiert und womöglich doch keine große Lust hat, sein Verein Champions League regelmäßig zu sehen.
Und ist dann diese beste Platzierung, die man bisher in seiner Geschichte hatte, nämlich 19, 20, da war man ja dritter, ist das dann im Nachhinein so ein bisschen Fluch, dass man vielleicht Rennes auch besser einschätzt, als sie sind, weil du hast ja nicht jedes Jahr ein Ousmane Dembele im Kader. Und stimmt natürlich alles, was du sagst, wenn man sich die Transfers anguckt. Da geht viel hin und her. Aber wo wäre denn das naturelle Habitat von Rennes in der Tabelle? Wo müssten die eigentlich liegen?
Also vom Budget her und von der Vereinstruktur mit dieser herausragenden Jugendabteilung eigentlich schon im mindestens Europakonferenzkrieg gestreiten. Also schon im Top 6, 7 sein. Im ersten, oberen Tabellen Drittel, das ist klar. Weil, wie gesagt, mit Pino, der schon viel Geld hat, hat man auch ein gutes Budget. Und daraus wurde zuletzt wenig gemacht. Du hast es gesagt, 3. damals, auch eine tolle Champions League-Kampagne geliefert, da war viel Euphorie dabei, aber danach kam zu wenig. Man hat vielleicht zu sehr gedacht, man wird es jetzt so schaffen, weil man merkt auch, Marseille, Lyon oder Monaco sind alles andere als konstant. Und das wäre vielleicht eine Nische, wo man da reingehen könnte bei Rhein. Und das hat wirklich nicht geklappt. Vielleicht haben einige ja die Realität aus den Augen verloren. Und jetzt kommt die Quittung. Und deswegen ist dieser Weg oder diese Entwicklung vielleicht doch nicht so überraschend.
Also wieder einiges los. Und wieder hervorragende Investorenbeispiele haben wir wieder in dieser Sendung. Muss man wirklich sagen, das ist so der kleine Untertitel der Ligatur. Spaß mit Investoren. Was ist eigentlich, wenn die vielleicht nicht so viel Ahnung vom Fußball haben oder schlechte Entscheidungen treffen? Das ist so ein roter Faden. Ein anderer war ein aktueller, den wir mit Blick auf Spanien in den letzten Wochen hatten. Denn natürlich gab es da die Unwetter und eben damit zusammenhängen immer wieder kleinere Themen, die wir hier angesprochen haben. Und jetzt, Alex, gibt es nochmal einen Grund, über dieses Thema im größeren Rahmen zu sprechen. Ja, genau. Der FC Valencia durfte wieder Fußball spielen, ist zurückgekehrt ins Mestalla. Erstes Heimspiel seit der Flutkatastrophe. Die vorherigen beiden Spiele wurden ja verschoben. Es wäre ein Heimspiel gewesen gegen Real Madrid und ein Auswärtsspiel, ich weiß nicht mehr wo, wurde verschoben, weil natürlich die Region der Verein, die Stadt, ganz andere Sorgen hatten, als Fußball zu spielen. Auch weil das Mestalla quasi zum Hilfszentrum wurde, also im Stadion wurden Hilfsgüter gesammelt etc. Also der Verein hat sich wirklich in der Community da so engagiert, dass es einfach Wichtiges gab als schnöde Fußballspiele. Und jetzt eben nach zwei abgesagten Spielen endlich wieder ein Heimspiel. Und das wurde ganz, ganz, ich will nicht sagen feierlich zelebriert, weil es war ja nichts zu feiern, das wäre das falsche Wort. Aber es war ganz, ganz besonders emotional. Vor dem Spiel wurde ein Mosaik, eine Choreografie der Valenzianischen Fahne übers ganze Stadion hochgezogen. Das sah wirklich wunder, wunderschön aus oder einfach besonders aus. Dann auch eine 50-Meter-Fahne von Valencia. Also der Stadt der Community wurde auf dem Feld ausgebreitet. Dazu wurde die Hymne Valencians gespielt mit Blasinstrumenten. Das hat Tradition in Valencia. Und dementsprechend war da ein ganz, ganz besonderes Ambiente vor dem Spiel gegen Betis. Und Spieler waren zu Tränen gerührt, trugen schwarze Trikots. Es gab auch noch einen riesigen Banner mit den Stadtteilen und den Städten und Ortschaften, die von der Flutkatastrophe heimgesucht wurden. Die wurden auch quasi geehrt oder an die gedacht. Also ein ganz, ganz besonderes Ambiente. Ganz großes Spiel für den FC Valencia, für die Stadt Valencia. Und das Schöne ist, sie haben es auch noch 4 zu 2 gewonnen in diesem emotionalen Spiel. Also das ist so die Story von diesem La Liga-Spieltag, dass da in Valencia was ganz Besonderes passiert ist, das mehr als nur Fußball ist, das mehr als nur ein schnödes Ergebnis ist, sondern wirklich für die Stadt, für die Region, für die Menschen, für die Betroffenen, die ja teilweise auch ihr Leben verloren haben oder ihr Hab und Gut, dass die irgendwie mal was hatten, worüber sie sich freuen können quasi oder irgendwas, was sie zusammenbringt. Das stand so über diesem Spiel Valencia gegen Betis. Und wie gesagt, nicht nur, dass es so zelebriert wurde oder geehrt wurde, sondern dass sie hinteraus dann auch noch 4 zu 2 gewonnen haben in diesem emotionalen Spiel war schon was ganz, ganz Besonderes. Also ich habe die von dir angesprochene Choreo gesehen. Da hat man schon, also alleine von den Bildern her, wusste man schon, wie groß dieser Moment war. Und wenn man das so ein bisschen verfolgt hat, es wurde ja zum Beispiel, ganz lange sollte ja noch ein MotoGP-Rennen, ganz wichtig für die Weltmeisterschaft, sollte in Valencia stattfinden. Dann wurde es endlich irgendwann verschoben, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit der Situation vor Ort beschäftigt. Es kennt eigentlich jeder, jeder der vor Ort lebt, kennt mindestens einen, der alles verloren hat. Und im schlimmsten Fall vielleicht sogar das Leben Angehöriger. Also ich habe diese Choreo gesehen und habe eben auch gesehen bei Blue Sky und bei Mastodon, wie groß dieser Moment war. Und dann habe ich am nächsten Tag gesehen, oh, 4-2 gewonnen, Mensch, das freut mich ja. Und dann gucke ich mir den Torverlauf an und sehe, aha, 1 zu 1 ab der 14. Minute und dann 50. Minute 2 zu 1, 53. Minute 3 zu 1, 56. Minute 4 zu 1. Hat sich da im Positiven was gelöst? Also kann man da noch was rauslesen? Das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass quasi dem Verein geht es ja auch nicht gut sportlich. Ist auch im Abstiegskampf ganz unten waren, glaube ich, Tabellen letzter, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Haben jetzt erst den zweiten Saisonsieg und das Sieg quasi durch diese verheerende, schlimme Sache, dass sie daraus offenbar auch sportlich Kraft ziehen und vielleicht für den Verein, für die Mannschaft selber, das so ein kleines Erweckungserlebnis sein kann. Zumindest war es das in diesem Spiel, ist auch die sportliche Note, die da zusammenkommt. Und es ist natürlich dann auch interessant, dass aus so etwas Negativen der ganze Verein offenbar so Kraft ziehen kann und die Mannschaft auch, dass die auch sportlich dann gute Schlagzeilen liefern. Und wie gesagt, es stand ja nicht im Vordergrund dieses Fußballspiel an sich. Das Sportliche war nebenher, man musste ja spielen, aber dass sie so Kraft daraus ziehen können für die Community, für den Verein, für die Gesellschaft, für die Menschen, die im Stadion sind, aber auch von den Fernsehern ist eben ja die Story, die oben drüber liegt, also da gibt es nach dem Spiel ein ganz, ganz schönes Zitat von Ruben Barracher, das muss ich jetzt kurz mal vorlesen, der das, finde ich, wirklich schön zusammengefasst hat. Er hat gesagt, die Emotionen, die wir empfanden, er selber hatte eine Gänsehaut, wir wollten für die Opfer und für alle Betroffenen spielen und sie ehren, wir wollten für die da sein, die es betroffen hat, sie sollen wissen, dass wir für sie da sind, wir wollen der Gesellschaft zur Seite stehen, wir wollen, dass diejenigen ihr Leben zurückbekommen, auch wenn das nicht so bald geschehen wird, werden wir es trotzdem nie vergessen. Wenn diejenigen, die ins Stadion gekommen sind, die im Fernsehen zugeschaut haben oder die nur das Ergebnis gesehen haben, ein wenig jetzt lächeln können, wenn wir denjenigen ihren Tag nur ein bisschen verändert haben, auf irgendeine kleine Weise ihnen geholfen haben, etwas Spaß zu empfinden, dann haben wir etwas erreicht. Und das ist das, wofür wir spielen. Also das sind wirklich, finde ich, besondere Worte, die er wirklich sehr, sehr schön gewählt hat. Und ich glaube, das fasst das Ganze zusammen. Die Emotionen, die hat die Mannschaft wirklich auf den Rasen bekommen und dann in ein tolles Spiel umgewandelt. Und so wurde aus diesem Spiel dann wirklich ein großes Ganzes auch für die Mannschaft sehr positiv. Ja, und gibt Valencia auch im sportlichen Sinne dann wieder Hoffnung? Jetzt ist man dran. Man hat ja eben noch die Nachholspiele. Das heißt, der Theorie nach könnte man sich sogar rausspielen aus der Abstiegszone, in der man gerade noch drin hängt. Aber ja, wir sind sehr gespannt darauf. Ich glaube vor allem dieses Espanyol-Basaloner-Spiel. Das wird natürlich wichtig, dass verlegt wurde. Es findet jetzt am 18.12. statt, also eine Woche vor Weihnachten. Espanyol gerade punktgleich mit Valencia 19., Valencia 18. Sind wir gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Schon interessant, welches Themenspektrum wir hier im Laufe der Zeit haben mit so der Ligatur. Und das wird jetzt nicht weniger werden, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn jetzt kommen wir in den Bereich, wir hatten unsere großen Themen und jetzt machen wir kleinere, kürzere Themen. Wir wollen über Persönlichkeiten sprechen, wir wollen über Geschichten sprechen, die wichtig sind. Jeder hat drei Schüsse quasi dafür. Christian, du darfst gerne mal beginnen. Wer wäre denn so eine Person oder ein Ereignis, was du jetzt gerne mal hier kurz beleuchten würdest?
Also ich fange mal an mit, wie ist der mal formerly known bei uns oder mit der MVP-Kategorie. Da habe ich mir Herrn Matthias Zaccagni rausgenommen, den Lazio-Kapitän. Lazio hat die letzten 7 Pflichtspiele alle gewonnen, steht in der Tabelle, ist ja Teil dieses besonders Skudetto-Kampfs, fünf Mannschaften innerhalb von einem Punkt, also ist auch nur ein Punkt hinter Napoli. Und Zaccagni hat in den letzten drei Serie-A-Spielen immer getroffen, steht jetzt schon bei sechs Saison-Toren. Und ist seit dem Sommer neuer Kapitän bei der Lazio, da gab es einen großen Umbruch, Emi Morbile nicht mehr da, Luis Alberto nicht mehr da. Er wurde zum Kapitän ernannt. Das hat am Anfang so ein bisschen für Kritika auch gesorgt, weil da gab es doch ein, zwei andere Spieler im Kader, die mehr Einsätze für Lazio hatten. Aber rückblickend haben sie alles richtig gemacht, denn dieser Kapitänsspiel, der hat ihm wirklich auch nochmal mehr Verantwortung gegeben. Und ein paar erinnern sich hier vielleicht noch sein. Einer der wenigen schönen Momente der italienischen EM im Sommer, das schöne Siegtor gegen Kroatien. Also Zaccani war immer schon ein feiner Fußballer, aber oft einer, der in Sachen Kontinuität hat etwas missen lassen. Und jetzt ist er Kapitän dieser großartig aufspielenden Lazio-Mannschaft. Lazio wirklich, muss man sagen, wir hatten heute Atalanta. Interlogisch auch, aber Lazio spielt mit den attraktivsten, offensivsten Fußballer Serie A. Und Zaccani eben 6 Saison-Tore, immer wieder diese Del Piero-Tore, also dieses von links reinziehend ins lange Eck schlänzen. Del Piero war auch sein großes Vorbild immer gewesen. Und letzter Punkt dazu. Mittlerweile hatten wir oft die linken Seiten in Italien, also Leao plus Deo Hernandez, die sich durchaus sehen lassen kann, wenn sie gerade Lust hat. Dann würde ich die Marco Bastoni da reinnehmen, die interlinke Seite, die herausragend ist. Und mittlerweile, seit dieser Saison, muss man sagen, Zaccani plus Nuno Tavares, der hier auch schon stattgefunden hat unter den MVPs, also mittlerweile auch einen der spielstärksten linken Angriffssaiten in der Serie A, also Zaccani, auf einem sehr, sehr guten Weg.
Sag mal, du erzählst uns immer die ganze Zeit von so tollem Offensivfußball. Ist das wirklich so, dass es– also wie viele Teams gibt es denn bitte in der Serie A, die gerne den Ball haben wollen und damit was Positives machen wollen?
Ja, ziemlich viele mittlerweile. Das ist– also da kann man ja auch mal eine eigene Abhandlung machen. Aber also da, da Serie A fällt, dass der Cut, das Rasenfunk, das nur noch ein großes Thema pro Sendung gibt, in dieser Konstellation aktuell auf die Füße, weil es gibt wirklich viele schöne Geschichten. Und einer davon ist auch Lazio, definitiv.
Man muss wirklich mehr Serie A gucken. Es ist echt ein Jammer, dass ich da aus offensichtlichen Gründen nicht so sehr dazukomme. Weniger Augsburg-Hoffenheim, Max, und mehr Serie A. Ja, eigentlich ja. Aber was soll ich tun? Man kann nicht auf seine Haut.
Letzter Satz, sorry dazu. Bei Lazio läuft es ja europäisch auch. Es ist ja die einzige Mannschaft, die bisher alle vier Europa League-Spieler gewonnen hat. Also sie transportieren das auch in Europa, sozusagen bislang in dieser Saison.
Ja, verrückt. Okay, also wir sehen die Serie A, sie ist am Blühen. Aber das haben wir hier in der Ligatour schon länger begleitet. Jetzt schauen wir nochmal nach England. Und Uli darf uns nochmal ein Thema mitbringen. Uli, über wen oder was würdest du gerne kurz sprechen?
Ich glaube, es ist sinnvoll und auch in der Reihenfolge, auch wenn ich dann mit der alten Tradition Final aufräume, über Manchester City zu sprechen, weil die Dinge, die in der Champions League passiert sind, das Bild, das Pep Guardiola im wahrsten Sinne abgegeben hat, als auch dann die 4-0-Liederlage gegen Tottenham, die war schon besonders und die beide Ergebnisse und Leistungen kamen auch so, dass ich nicht zwingend damit gerechnet habe, weil ich schon geglaubt habe, 4-0-Liederlagen in Folge, das ist das eine, die standen vor der Länderspielpause, da haben wir schon Rüffel bekommen, warum wir das nicht thematisiert haben, war aber schon auch einigermaßen bewusst gewählt, weil ich, Bruder Leichtfuß, dachte, Ja, komm, geht jetzt alles in die richtige Richtung nach der Länderspielpause, aber das ist nicht so. Und auch wenn es gewisse Parallelen gibt zu der Situation von vor 18 Monaten und in der Saison 2022, 2023 sind sie dann am Ende Champions-League-Sieger, Meister und FA Cup-Sieger geworden, alles gut. Aber so in der Deutlichkeit habe ich es noch nicht gesehen. Und es kommen natürlich jetzt, also logischerweise versucht man ja irgendwie, draufzukommen, was könnte es denn sein. Und dann kommen ein paar Dinge jetzt ans Licht, die ich logischerweise vorher kannte, auch auf dem Schirm hatte, aber nicht so bewertet hätte, die man vielleicht jetzt anders bewerten muss, auch wenn ich dir jetzt schon sagen kann, nach der geschweiften Klammer steht ein, die sind immer noch Tabellen 2. Und ja, Liverpool könnte theoretisch plus 11 am Sonntag als Tabellenführer dastehen. Aber es ist halt Manchester City. Ich kann einfach noch nicht aus meiner Haut und sagen, dass am 1. Dezember, dass ich dann sage, herzlichen Glückwunsch zur Meisterschaft Liverpool, auch wenn man den Chaos aufmachen kann. Also insbesondere nach dem Spiel gestern in der Champions League gegen Real Madrid, komme ich immer mehr zu dem Ergebnis, dass ich eventuell nochmal richtig korrigieren muss in meiner Einordnung von 1, 2 und 3 in der Premier League, die ich ja ziemlich stark getroffen hatte vor der Saison und bei der ich auch irgendwann vor vier oder sechs Wochen nochmal geblieben bin. Liverpool ist legit, das ist, glaube ich, so. Aber City ist jetzt nicht die größte Thekenmannschaft der Welt, sondern es gibt Erklärungen für das, was da gerade passiert, auch wenn die wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig zufriedenstellend sind.
Ja, aber was sind denn das für Erklärungen? Weil wenn man nur von außen draufguckt, natürlich Rotri-Verletzung. Das haben wir jetzt alle schon tausendmal. Da kommt man ja auch selber drauf. Aber ich habe gestern die Champions League nur so über Ergebnisse verfolgt. Da habe ich gesehen, City führt rein. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, gut, jetzt haben sie ja die Kurve gekriegt.
Ja.
Und dann gucke ich eine halbe Stunde später drauf und es ist 3-3 ausgegangen.
Ja, also trotzdem, das, was alle wissen, muss ja nicht immer verkehrt sein. In dem Fall ist es richtig. Es geht alles los bei den Verletzungen und das kaufe ich auch weiterhin so. Aber, und jetzt kommt es, also Rotri fehlt, ja. Damit fehlt Athletik und Körpergröße im Mittelfeld. Jetzt haben sie vor der Saison auch aus PSA-Gründen. Julian Alvarez ziehen lassen und nicht nur. Der war auch chronisch unzufrieden. Dann haben sie ziehen lassen. Auch der hätte jetzt im Moment alles gestopft. Kevin de Broglie nicht da, stopft er. Kein Problem. Der ist wahnsinnig wichtig für die Athletik in der Truppe. Der hat super viele zweite Bälle aufgesammelt und der hat so gut wie jeden einzelnen Weg gemacht. Dann fehlt nicht nur Rotri, sondern sie können ihn nicht ersetzen, weil sie Kevin Phillips zu Recht im Übrigen haben ziehen lassen, mal wieder per Laie, weil der nie so funktioniert hat, wie das, was sie sich vorgestellt haben. Tut richtig weh. Sie können aber auf das 6 nicht nachlegen. Das heißt, sie müssen irgendwie schieben. Jetzt würde mir als allererstes in den Sinn kommen John Stones, der ist auch verletzt. Dann würde mir in den Sinn kommen Manolo Kanci. Nein, der ist verletzt. Nathan Arkay spielt zwar wieder, ist aber nicht gesund. Kyle Walker spielt die ganze Zeit, war nie gesund. Als nächstes ist Mateo Kovacic, der ist ziemlich klein und hat mit so viel Raum, den er covern muss, seine Probleme. Das heißt, da gibt es einfach so permanentes Schiebeverhalten, das ist nicht gut. Rico Lewis hat das teilweise gemacht, aber Rico Lewis ist halt ein Teenager und ich glaube im Übrigen, dass der nie, nach allem, was ich von dem gelesen habe, wird das nicht mal in die Nähe eines Führungsspielers geben bei dem. Kevin de Bruyne fehlt verletzungsbedingt. Von den Innenverteidigern war nie irgend einer jemals gesund. Erling Haaland kriegt gerade A nicht so die Bälle und trifft nicht. Wenn er nicht trifft, treffen andere auch nicht, weil Savino hat nicht das Profil. Das weiß Alex auch. Das sieht alles ganz nett aus und bis in den Strafraum ist es auch gut. Aber danach fehlt halt was. Selbiges gilt für Jeremie Doku. Jack Greelish ist verletzt und nicht in Form. Beide sind auch wechselseitig zum Teil. Und dann kann man schon irgendwann mal sagen, na gut, Gündoğan kommt zurück und ist einfach alt inzwischen. Ich will ihm gar nicht zu nahe treten, aber es ist halt nicht mehr der Spieler von vor drei Jahren. Und das ist so ein Punkt, das hat mir Christian vor dem Champions League-Finale damals gesagt. Und das war die Erkenntnis, die ich bis heute mitfrage und ihn immer wieder zitiere. Wenn Jeko nicht gespielt hätte, wäre der Altersschnitt von Inter, die man als alt verschrien hat, und City gleich gewesen. Ziemlich gleich. Also 0,1 irgendwas oder so. Und das ist der Kern, der immer noch spielt bei City. Und der Kader ist weiterhin aufgrund eben von Sorgen gegenüber PSA verschlankt worden. Das heißt, Guardiola spielt mit der 13. oder 14. Rotation. Und da durfte halt nichts passieren. Und das war klar. Und auf der einen Position durfte überhaupt gar nichts passieren. Und das ist passiert. Und ich glaube, der Rest ist dann einfach nur, wie es halt passiert im Fußball, wenn es mal so gar nicht läuft und du dich nie damit beschäftigt hast. Was passiert, wenn es nicht läuft? Weil es ist immer gelaufen. Phil Foden habe ich noch vergessen, der die Zeit letztes Jahr alles überschwingt hat mit einfachen Toren, die nicht hätten passieren dürfen. Dann kommt jetzt auch so die negative Dynamik rein. Das ist genau das, was wir bei Feyenoord gesehen haben. Du hast die nach dem ersten Tor zittern sehen. Dass die gedacht haben, oh nein, wir sind nur eigentlich durch. Bis dahin hätten die 7-0 führen müssen. Das ist ja auch immer noch rein strukturell das, was City am Ball zeigt. Ich habe auch die grundsätzliche Idee gegen Tottenham verstanden. Das ging dann schief, okay, aber Gott, Jola probiert was und wir haben zu Beginn der Saison, glaube ich, zumindest in einem Halbsatz auch mal hier drüber geredet, dass ich eine neue Struktur erkannt habe und die fand ich auch gut. Sie haben eigentlich zu Beginn der Saison besser performt, als ich das annahm, weswegen ich die Altersthematik, gealterter Kader, gleicher Kader und so eigentlich eher zurückgedrängt habe. Vielleicht muss ich es vorholen, wenngleich, du merkst schon, ich bin auch nicht ganz überzeugt davon. Ich kaufe das noch nicht, diese Krise. Das ist offensichtlich eine im Moment für City-Verhältnisse, aber ich bin jetzt nicht bereit zu sagen, komm, die sind Müll und die Ära ist beendet, oder was auch immer, alle schreien mir jetzt.
Ja, ach, das müssen wir jetzt, das ist ja völliger Quatsch, wir haben Herbst. Also heute ist hier der herbstigste Tag, den man sich vorstellen kann in München. Christian kann es bestätigen, Alexi auch. Also da ist noch, da wird noch viel Saison zu spielen sein, aber ich finde das unheimlich interessant, wie man so nebenbei hier in der Ligatur immer wieder so Grundthesen mitschleppen kann. Und das eine ist, da weise ich ja auch gerne immer drauf hin, Investoren sind nicht die Lösung, weil auch Investoren können Fehler machen. Und das zweite ist, als die PSA-Regeln kamen, sowohl in La Liga als auch in der Premier League, so unterschiedlich sie auch sind, aber so grob sind sie vergleichbar, da hatte man schon den Eindruck, ja gut, was soll jetzt die Großen einbremsen? Und dann haben wir gesehen, ok, Barca wird davon eingebremst und da hat uns Alex erklärt, ja, Corona hat die auch extrem hart getroffen und so weiter und so fort. Und es ist auch de facto so, dass diese PSA-Themen die Großen nicht so wirklich ganz krass einbremsen werden. Aber ein bisschen dann eben doch– und das ist doch interessant– dass wir dann in eine Situation kommen, in der der Kader von City nicht gut genug ist für das, was ihnen widerfahren ist. Mit dem konnte man nicht unbedingt rechnen und vielleicht hätten sie es auch, wenn sie ein Shoppen hätten gegen können, wie sie wollten, auch nicht aufgefangen. Aber es ist eine Teilerklärung. Und das finde ich doch sehr interessant. Und das nehme ich hier raus auch mit. Stichwort Gündoganer, den musste ja Basa abgeben, aus diesen Salärgründen, finanziellen Gründen, damit sie dann die Olme holen. Entweder oder, hieß es. Also allein daran siehst du schon, du kannst nicht mehr alles machen, wie du willst. Und offenbar bei City, naja gut, die finden immer Schlupflöcher.
Die haben ihn ja auch nur genommen, weil es halt machbar war. Und dachten, damit können sie, damit können sie, also nicht nur, schon klar, das ist ein sehr verdienter Spieler in der Clubhistorie, aber sie hatten eigentlich damit abgeschlossen. Die haben den ja nur geholt, weil er halt ablösefrei war und nur in Anführungszeichen das Gehalt, aber das wird anders gegen die Bilanz gerechnet. Und für Hohle an hast du das Geld bekommen.
Also ein bisschen was bringt es, ne? Ein bisschen was bringt es eben. Es ist doch nett, es wird zusammengestaucht.
Darf ich noch einen ganz kurzen… Ich weiß nicht, ob es euch ähnlich ging. Uli hat das ja wunderbar alles erklärt. Jetzt auf das letzte Spiel, auf das Champions League-Spiel nach diesem 3-0. Ich weiß nicht, ging es euch ähnlich. Ich finde, da war für mich wieder zumindest schon die Magie des Fußballs, dass spätestens nach dem 3-2 wusstest du eigentlich, da wird es 3-3 fallen. Du wusstest es. Du wusstest es. Es wird kommen. Es ist eine Frage, wann ist es? Ist es die 89er, die 90er, die 94er? Und das finde ich das Beispiel so beeindruckend, weil es kann auch Manchester City treffen. Also es kann auch die Mannschaft treffen, die wahrscheinlich über die letzten Jahre am meisten Selbstvertrauen haben sollte, die den Trainer hat, der über alle Zeiten als der gelten wird, der am meisten Innovation gebracht hat. Aber selbst die kann es in solchen Momenten erwischen. Ich habe das Spiel nicht live gesehen, aber ich habe es im Ticker gesehen und danach hatte es eine Pharma-Fassung. Und wie Ulo ja auch gesehen hast, du hast die Angst in den Augen der Spieler gesehen. Und das finde ich ist das Magische vom Fußball, dass das auch Man City und Pep Guardiola passieren kann.
Deswegen glaube ich bewegt es auch so viele Leute, dieses City-Ding. Weil die waren die Einzigen im Weltfußball, selbst Real Madrid, die haben am Ende immer gewonnen. Aber selbst Real Madrid hatte mal Phasen, wo man dachte, ach guck mal, so gut ist das gar nicht. Aber City hatte das halt nie. Das war ja wirklich roboterartig. Und deswegen glaube ich bewegt es so viele Menschen. Da ist auch natürlich viel Helme dabei. Da kann ich immer nicht so viel mit anfangen. Aber die grundsätzlichen Fragen nach diesem Thema, die waren jetzt schon da. Die habe ich oft, oft und viel bekommen. Und weil halt auch Menschen wissen wollen, sagen sie, ach guck mal, doch nicht oder was. Und es liegt nicht an Guardiola. Das kann ich schon mal sagen. Das glaube ich wirklich nicht. Ich glaube das überhaupt gar nicht. Auch nur 1% kauf ich das. Es lief halt alles sau blöd aus ihrer Sicht. Und in England freuen sich auch alle. Die sagen auch alle, mega.
Ja, das müssen sie jetzt auch mal aushalten, dass sie jetzt halt mal meine Güte. Es ist ja wie wenn Bayern hier mal ein paar Spiele verliert. Ihr werdet es alle überleben. Aber die Schönheit des Spiels sieht man wirklich an solchen Spielen. Das hatten wir ja gestern noch bei dem Spiel. Ich meine, Schachtur führt auswärts in Eindhoven. 1 zu 2. Da denkt man sich schon so, oh, jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob es 90. 2 zu 2 gibt. Da weißt du schon, okay, jetzt werden sie nicht schnell abpfeifen. Und zack, 95. Minute. Ricardo Peffi, wie wir es immer alle wussten. Er kann es doch.
Und Roger Stern-Belgrad müssen wir auch erwähnen an der Stelle. Das ist auch eine besondere Geschichte dieser Europapokalwoche, die special ist bis jetzt, muss man fairerweise sagen.
Es ist so ärgerlich, dass ich das noch nicht sehen konnte. Aber gut, was habe ich gemacht? Eure Honorarabrechnung und das, was mehr als wert, liebe Leute. Um 21 Uhr?
Ja, naja, du siehst ja.
Ganz kurz noch sportlich, weil Uli Pepp natürlich genannt hat. Da will ich ganz kurz einhaken. Uli, der Mann braucht einen Serbettickel. Können wir uns da bitte einig sein?
Das würde er dann schon machen in ein, ein halb Jahren knapp.
Im Sommer, im Sommer braucht er das Serbettickel.
Nein, nein.
Der braucht einen Serbettickel. Schauen Sie doch an, der zerkratzt sich die Stirn. Der ist ja fix und alle der Typ.
Ja, das würde er aber auch machen, wenn er zu Hause allein am Sofa sitzt und das Spiel schaut. Also nein.
Also ich sage, der Mann braucht einen Serbettickel. Das sollte im Sommer kommen. Da wäre ja sein Vertrag ausgelaufen. Oder läuft er aus? Hat er ihn schon verlängert oder wird er einfach? Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Ich finde, der braucht einen Serbettickel. Das sieht man ja jetzt wirklich. Und dann kann er mal wieder, weiß ich nicht, in New York, in Tokio mal wieder ein Jährchen Pause machen. Und dann kann er ja zum Beispiel in die Serie A, Christian. Ne, ich spiele viel zu offensiv. Das passt nicht. Die spielen ja jetzt offensiv, geht das nicht? Also das wäre mein Ratschlag an ihn, einen Serbettickel-Junge, komm. Das geht so nicht weiter. Ich sage euch, es dauert nur noch ein Unentschieden oder ein Punktverlust von Manchester City, bis endlich die These kommt, dass seitdem Jürgen Klopp raus ist aus der Premier League, in der psychologische Widersacher fehlt und jetzt hat er das schon so. Ach mein Gott. Ja, du bist ja nicht mehr auf Twitter, da gibt es die These schon.
Das ist echt so? Das habe ich noch nicht gelesen, aber stimmt.
Sport-Journalismus ist der beste Journalismus überhaupt. Die beiden haben sich gegenseitig gebraucht, es ist der eine weg, plötzlich geht bei City nichts mehr und Slott spaziert.
Ja, und Slott ist auch nur eine Luftpumpe.
Schau mal her, Liverpool kann ja sogar Real Madrid schlagen. Klopp konnte das nicht, ich glaube, er hat sieben Spiele in Folge gegen Real verloren und Slott hat nicht mehr City. Die Klopp-Fesseln sind gelöst, endlich hat es mal jemand gesagt. So nehme ich. Na gut, dann haben wir doch noch ein weiteres Take-Away. So, jetzt gucken wir aber mal bei jemandem, bei dem sich auch die Fesseln gelöst haben, nämlich Pierre-Emil Heubier. Was ist denn bei dem los bei Olympique, Alexi?
Ich freue mich auch, was macht der in Marseille eigentlich? Das ist nichts Besseres. Vor allem, die spielen ja international in dieser Saison gar keinen Wettbewerb. Aber was mir gefällt, er bringt diese Siegermentalität mit, die Marseille unbedingt braucht, weil die hat zum Beispiel Adrian Rabiot überhaupt nicht. Und das tut aber in jedem Fall der Mannschaft richtig gut, auch wenn Marseille immer wieder schwankt, aber bei den Leistungen. Aber der bringt wirklich viel Power mit, viel Dynamik, viel Energie rein. Und er tut der Mannschaft gut, nur wohin geht die Reise? Das ist schon die Frage. Sollte Marseille in dieser Saison wieder dort nicht so gut abschneiden, nämlich in die Champions League dort nicht zurückkehren, in der kommenden Spielzeit dann wieder wahrscheinlich gehen, weil er ist auch gekommen, um irgendwann mal wieder die Königsklasse zu bestreiten, auch wenn er die nie so oft gespielt hat, auch mit Tottenheim nicht. Aber seine Entscheidung war schon mutig, muss man ganz klar sagen. Aber er ist der Chef in dieser Mannschaft. Er darf die Freischüsse sehr oft schießen. Das war erfolgreich in Lens mit seinem Siegtreffer. Deswegen auf der einen Seite eine mutige Entscheidung von ihm, auf der anderen will er zeigen, dass er schon sehr erfahren geworden ist, sehr reif. Aber ob die Entscheidung nachher gut war von ihm, da kann man schon noch gewisse Zweifel haben, weil einfach der Verein nebulös geführt wird und nach wie vor keiner weiß, wo es genau hingeht.
Aber aktuell liegt Marseille auf einem Champions-League-Rang 3. Und ich meine, klar, wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen. Die ganz großen Hoffnungen, dass man PSG vielleicht einen Bein stellen könnte, die hat sich jetzt nicht erfüllt. Aber bisher scheint es doch aufgegangen zu sein für ihn. Er kann ja Champions League vielleicht spielen nächste Saison.
Vielleicht, aber die Saison ist noch lang. Und wie gesagt, im Gegensatz zu Monaco, Lille oder PSG, hat Marseille eine ganze Woche frei. Jetzt hat man einen Trainingslager absolviert die ganze Woche, weil man ein wichtiges richtungsweisendes Spiel hat am Sonntagabend gegen Monaco. Zu Hause tut man sich eh sehr, sehr schwer, auch gegen direkte Konkurrenten, und da will man ein Zeichen setzen. Deswegen ist es eine sehr wichtige Partie am Sonntag. Und wenn das wieder schiefgehen sollte, dann habe ich große Zweifel, dass Marseille sein Ziel erreicht und in den Top 4 am Saisonende landet.
Gut, über die Stärke von Monaco haben wir natürlich auch schon gesprochen. Also Sonntagabend um 20.45 Uhr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da habt ihr auf jeden Fall ein Spiel, das man sich mal angucken könnte. Marseille zu Hause gegen Monaco, Rang 3 gegen Rang 2. Wir werden genau verfolgen, was bei Marseille passiert. Und dann blicken wir auch nochmal nach Spanien. Alex, über was möchtest du da gerne sprechen? Ja, wenn wir jetzt schon Real Madrid gedroppt haben, den Namen, und Uli die Europa Cup-Woche so davon schwärmte, kann man das natürlich ganz kurz, weil es ein kleines Thema aufgreifen, was da gestern in der Enfield Road passiert ist. Wir haben ja normalerweise hier den Award MVP, Most Valuable Player. Ich tanze mal aus der Reihe, mache aus dem V ein D. MDP, Most Disappointing Player, und nenne Kylian Mbappé nach der gestrigen Leistung. Ist er tatsächlich im Fokus der Medien, also eh schon in der Saison, weil er ein paar Elfmeter reingemacht hat und hier und da einen Abstauber, zum Beispiel ein Leganes, aber viel mehr eben nicht. Und jetzt war Vinicius Junior an der Enfield Road verletzt und er durfte endlich mal wieder links spielen. Vorne war eine falsche Neun, wurscht, die haben gar keinen richtigen Stürmer. Er wurde als Stürmer geholt, ne, ne, er möchte links spielen, alles klar. Tun wir Brahim Diaz vorne rein, damit wir ihn akkommodieren. Und was er geleistet hat, war überschaubar. Und natürlich durch den verschossenen Elfmeter rückt er ganz, ganz groß in den Fokus der spanischen Medien und ist quasi so der Schuldige, der gestrigen Niederlage oder der Posterboy im negativen Sinne, auf den sich alles ablädt. Und deswegen MDP, Kylian Mbappé, der wirklich schwer enttäuscht, seitdem er bei Real Madrid ist. Aber also ich nehme jetzt mal an, dass dir die Erklärung erster Alleinschuldige oder der Hauptschuldige zu kurz gegriffen ist. Nein, ich sage, das mediale Echo ist tatsächlich durch den verschossenen Elfmeter, dadurch rückt er so in den Fokus, dass man das natürlich kurz hier mal thematisieren kann, auch weil ihr natürlich da Input geben könnt, wie ihr das außenstehend seht. Aber in Spanien wird er wirklich gerade bei den Real Madrid-Fans. Also ich bin ja weiterhin auf Twitter noch aktiv, was du da mitbekommst an Memes. Da gibt es ja dieses eine Meme, da sind zwei Wege. Links ist so ein glänzendes, schönes Schloss und rechts so eins, das nach Darkness aussieht. Und dann wurde ein Bild. Links das schöne Schloss ist Vinicio Junior. Also er steht am Weg, Mbappé. Links ist Vinicio Junior und rechts ist Eden Hazard. Der schlechte Weg. Und er entscheidet sich für den Weg nach rechts. Also er wird schon mit Flop-mäßig mit Eden Hazard so leicht verglichen oder es geht die Tendenz schon in die Richtung, dass er ein Megaflop sein könnte.
Da würde ich mir noch ein bisschen Zeit schassen.
Ich sag nur, wie das Medienecho, das ich so wahrnehme, auch ist. Dann weiß er heutzutage Social Media, da wird schnell jemand hochgejubelt und wieder fallen gelassen, wenn es nicht läuft. Aber es ist nicht gut, was da Mbappé macht. Also der wirkt wirklich. Deswegen haben wir Alex ist ja hier, deswegen kann man es wunderschön ansprechen. Wie ein Schatten seiner selbst, seiner Hochzeit. Und wie alt ist er? 26? Er spielt als wenn er 36 wäre, tatsächlich. Also wirklich, ja, glattfach.
Ich finde das nicht.
Aber Alexi, wie denkst du darüber?
Ich meine, generell muss man ja sagen, Mbappé ist ja auch noch anders in den Schlagzeilen. Also es gibt einen Vergewaltigungsvorwurf. Das ist bisher nur ein Vorwurf. Und das ist, während er nicht beim Nationalteam war, selbstgewehrt vorgefallen. Und es gibt ja auch mit dem Nationalteam Themen, also dass er sagt, er fühlt sich nicht fit, kann nicht spielen, spielt dann, glaube ich, drei Tage, nachdem er das gesagt hat, spielt er dann für Real. Wie das ankommt, kann man sich ja auch vorstellen. Wie würdest du denn auf Mbappé und seine Situation gerade blicken?
Seine Krise dauert schon eigentlich seit einem Jahr. Also die letzten sechs Monate bei Paris Saint-Germain war auch eine reine Katastrophe. Natürlich hat er seine 40 Buden gemacht, aber wie der Verein mit ihm umging, die Scheiß, die ihn unheimlich viel Druck gemacht haben und dann bedroht haben, weil er nicht verlängert hat, es war menschlich für ihn einfach nicht mehr auszuhalten. Da hatte ich sehr, sehr schlecht gefühlt in diesem Verein. Der Abschied fiel eigentlich ganz kurz aus, obwohl er sehr, sehr viel für den Verein geleistet hat. Innerhalb von sieben Jahren hat er alle Rekorde gebrochen und wird bedankt, wie Levin Kursawa einer der drei Spiele pro Jahr gemacht hat. Das war schon heftig, daran hat er bis heute zu knabbern, ganz klar. Und dann der Wechsel zu Real. Er ist einfach zu spät gewechselt. Der hätte vor zwei Jahren schon mal wechseln sollen, weil damals war Viniicius auch noch nicht so weit wie heute. Wäre er die Nummer 1 gewesen auf dem linken Flügel, hätte sich den heutigen Stress mit dem Brasilianer gespart. Und der damals hat auch Real 180 Millionen geboten. Aber bei PSG darfst du den Verein nicht aus eigenem Wunsch verlassen. Sonst sind die Scheiße einfach stocksauer. Das hat man jetzt gesehen bei Mbappé, aber auch bei anderen Spielern. Man nehmen mal Muster gehen, weil er einfach nichts mehr geleistet hat. Messi war auch am Ende seiner Saison schon lange. Und deswegen hat man da keine Steine in den Weg geworfen. Aber bei Mbappé war es anders. Man wollte noch einige Jahre die Mannschaft komplett bauen. Sein Abgang war einfach nur Stress. Viel schlimmer als bei einer Scheidung. Das war schon heftig. Und bei Real ist es eine andere Welt. Aber du hast diese Privataffäre genannt. Schlimmer ist, dass er im Kopf eine Blockade hat. Und es ist die Frage, geht er in Richtung Ronaldo Messi oder in Richtung Neymar? Geht er in Richtung Weltklasse und vielleicht in die Geschichte eingehen? Oder geht er in Richtung größte Verschwindung aller Zeiten? Das ist ein schwieriger Spagat. Und die nächsten Monate werden wir uns das zeigen. Aber du sagst es gestern bei seiner Körpersprache, allein beim Elfmetern gesehen, er ist einfach schlau schlecht drauf gerade, nah an der Depression. Das übertreibe ich überhaupt nicht. Das ist einfach so. Das sagen auch viele Leute um ihn herum in Frankreich. Dass er momentan wirklich nah an der Depression ist. Du würdest sagen, er verdient 70 Millionen im Jahr, aber er spielt nicht nur Geld in der Rolle. Momentan ist er in einem sehr wichtigen Punkt nicht nur seiner Karriere, sondern in seinem Leben.
Aber Alexi, ganz kurz, findest du wirklich, dass Mbappé von der Bewertung her, dass man da auch wirklich, womöglich geht er in den Nehme weg? Ich finde, Mbappé hat in seiner Karriere auch schon zu viel geleistet, gerade allein mit der Nationalmannschaft. Er ist nur mit einer Kieße, gar keine Frage. Aber findest du echt, dass man ihn da so auf die Schiene stellen kann, dass er womöglich noch quasi– wie meint er, so größte Verschwendung oder so? Also ich finde, dafür hat er auch schon zu viel geliefert.
Wenn man sein Potenzial sieht, muss einfach viel mehr kommen. Und seit zwei Jahren stagniert er komplett. Hättest du gedacht, dass er mal nach Stockholm geht, weil es dort richtig gute Frauen gibt? Hättest du gedacht, dass er mal nach dem Vollgas geht, weil in den letzten Monaten hätte man nicht gedacht, dass er in diese Spirale reinfällt. Man hat schon gedacht, dass er Top-Profi ist, der alles daran setzt, dass er seine Ziele erreichen kann, wie Ronaldo, wie Messi und nicht wie Neymar. Und das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Aber Paris ist auch eine Stadt, wo man auch gerne nachts unterwegs ist. Und in dieser Spirale ist er leider gefallen. Und in Madrid gibt es auch scheinbar gute Clubs, glaube ich, Alex. Und in diesem Fall ist es sehr schwierig. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich nach Liverpool gehen sollen oder nach Dortmund.
Da gibt es auch gute Clubs, glaube ich, in Liverpool, ne? Dortmund nicht, wahrscheinlich, aber Liverpool schon. Ich will es ja sportlich nur betrachten. Alles andere steht mir…
Aber ich spiele auch eine Rolle. Du kannst das nicht…
Ich kann eine Rolle spielen, klar. Dass er psychologisch nicht frei ist, ich glaube, das siehst du auf dem Platz irgendwie schon. Dass es nicht läuft. Die Gründe, da will ich jetzt nicht spekulieren. Ich will nur das Sportliche bewerten oder analysieren. Und was ich da sehe, ist einfach wirklich gemessen an dem, was er zu leisten im Stande ist, welche Standinge er hat, was man sich von ihm erhofft. Ist das zu wenig? Und die Kritik ist eben enorm groß. Gerade aus dem medialen Real Madrid Lager, weil ja die Medienkonzentration in Madrid die größte ist mit den ganzen Tageszeitungen und Radiosendern und eben auch aus dem Fanlager, was ich da wahrnehme. Die schießen sich auf ihn ein, weil er enorm enttäuscht sportlich. Und darauf wollte ich nur kurz zu sprechen kommen. Uli Schüttel, den kommt. Ja, also bei allen. Er trägt das gar nicht, diese ganze Situation. Braucht Man City noch einen Flügel? Ich habe gehört, Doku unzufrieden und so. Kann er ja in dem Sommer noch fliegen.
Nö, der ist nicht unzufrieden.
Sie sind unzufrieden mit ihm.
Ja, meine ich ja, meine ich ja. Das meine ich.
Der ist 25.
Spielt wie 35.
Ach komm jetzt, hör auf. Also selbst wenn die Karriere jetzt endet, kannst du schon einen Haken dahinter machen und sagen, ja, das war ganz in Ordnung, weil der war schon zwei Weltmeisterschaftsfinals und hat beide entscheidend mitgeprägt.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das Zweite hat er fast allein gewonnen. Also ich finde, also sorry. Da siehst du mal, was die Erwartungshaltung ist, wenn der jetzt so real ist.
Aber das ist ja nicht seine Schuld. Also das eine ist ja, Kritik ist ja immer in Ordnung. Und das habe ich, ich habe ja das Spiel gestern gemacht. Ich habe ihn auch kritisiert. Aber das andere ist, ihn persönlich anzugehen, weil er kann ja nichts dafür für die überzogenen Erwartungshaltungen. Er kann auch nichts dafür, dass die jetzt zufällig einen haben, der ebenfalls von der linken Seite kommt. Und da haben sie jetzt die zwei der fünf besten potenziellen Fußballer.
Bei der Vereinsauswahl könntest du das bedenken, dass auf deiner Position einer ist, der Weltklasse ist und der gesetzt ist.
Ja gut, aber du kommst noch nicht… Also mein's ja… Na, dann geh ich nach Liverpool. Sondern du kommst da hin und sagst, okay, das kriegen wir schon hin. Also es gibt in der Geschichte des Sports mehrere Beispiele, wo man sich schon arrangiert. Und wenn ich Liganeske, es ist nur Liganeske, aber ich hab's gesehen, das Spiel, und da hab ich mir gedacht, ach so, es geht nämlich mit den beiden zusammen. Das könnte sogar ganz schön verheerend werden, wenn es mal geht. Und er ist, wir haben noch nicht mal Dezember. Das sind nicht mal vier Monate. Was ist denn los mit uns allen? Jetzt lass mal ihn halt mal ankommen da. Das ist immer noch ein junger Mann, der wahrscheinlich in den letzten sieben Jahren ist.
Ich bin nicht mehr so jung, der ist schon seit 17 Profi. Du kannst nicht.
Ja, das war eins der hitzigsten Segmente, das wir hier in der Ligatur hatten. Ich kann euch allerdings stand jetzt nicht sagen. Ihr seid schon schlauer als ich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie viel ihr davon gehört habt. Denn bei mir ist das Internet zusammengebrochen, und zwar komplett. Und deswegen müssen wir leider jetzt auch an dieser Stelle dann die Ligatur beenden. Aber ihr habt ja trotzdem über eine Stunde Content hier bekommen. Und wie ich hörte, hatten die anderen viel Spaß, als ich nicht mit dabei war. Man sieht, das Mbappé-Thema war gar nicht so schlecht gewählt, denn so emotional habe ich uns hier noch nie erlebt. Oh Mann, ich war nicht dabei.
Magst du das nochmal aufmachen hier oder was?
Mbappé, War Street Ronaldinho bei Barca. Aus Ruhlzeichen.
Nein.
Ich sage euch, also ich hoffe so sehr, dass es auf der Aufnahme drauf ist, denn ich will das auch jetzt hören. Ich will hören, über was ihr gesprochen habt. Ich weiß nur, dass ich hier wieder reingekommen bin, in diesem Meeting-Raum, und das war quasi wie, wenn so mehrere, so was im Fight-Club während der Brötchenpause. Alle hängen in den Seilen, alle sind verschwitzt und haben aber so ein Grinsen auf den Lippen. Ja, also ich hoffe, viel davon ist auf der Aufnahme gelandet. Es tut mir leid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. So ist es manchmal auch, dass wir jetzt dann an dieser Stelle diese Ligatur beenden müssen, aber das liegt außerhalb unserer Kraft. Ich danke euch Viren umso mehr, dass ihr euch gestritten und diskutiert habt. Alexi Menü, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel und Alex Treuker. Danke euch, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Und dann danke ich natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr wisst, alles, was ihr hier hört oder nicht gehört habt, ist von euch finanziert. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Ich danke in dieser Folge Paddypie, Mystiken, Lukas, Henne und der blau-gelben Datenwelt. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und es wird im Rasenfunk weitergehen. So ist denn das Internet zulässt. Und dann hört ihr uns auch bald hier wieder in einem Format eurer Wahl. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.
Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!